ibm cloud databases for data stacks
free cloud computing courses and two new
promotions for ibm cloud for vmware
solutions
all on this episode of ibm cloud now
what's up everyone my name is ian and
i'm back to bring you the latest and
greatest news and announcements
from ibm cloud jumping right in
we are thrilled to announce the general
availability of ibm cloud databases
for data stacks enterprise built on the
foundation of apache cassandra
datastax enterprise is a hybrid cloud
with scale-out data infrastructure
it gives you the freedom to run any
workload on any device in any cloud
with zero downtime at a global scale
datastax enterprise is now a first-class
citizen of the ibm cloud
meaning it runs natively as part of the
cloud platform and is supported and
managed by ibm engineers
it features operational reliability no
lock in
and zero downtime simply put
with best in class performance robust
security features and an open source
kubernetes operator
datastax enterprise is the ideal
database to engage enterprises for cloud
native data at scale
hit the link in the description of the
video for more information on how to get
started
with ibm cloud databases for data stacks
next up if you've already completed all
the puzzles in your home and you're
driving your family nuts with your
acoustic rendition of wonderwall
we've got something for you ibm is
offering free
online cloud computing courses and has
just released a new one
called introduction to containers
kubernetes and openshift
there are no prerequisites the course
can be completed in less than a day
and you'll earn the ibm containers in
kubernetes essentials badge
for this particular course topics
include an introduction to containers
container orchestration with kubernetes
scaling container based environments
and red hat open shift and the
kubernetes ecosystem
best of all this is just one of many
free courses from the ibm center for
cloud training
you can also try out introduction to
cloud ibm cloud essentials
and others as you work your way towards
a certification as an ibm cloud solution
advisor
if you're ready to take advantage of
some free learning see the link i've got
below
to close out this episode i want to let
you know about two new promotions for
ibm cloud for vmware solutions
you can now take advantage of three
month offers to help you get started at
no cost
with both veeam and kavonix risk
foresight
veeam provides a single platform for
modernizing backup
accelerating hybrid cloud and securing
customer data
together ibm and veeam have made the
journey to the cloud easier and faster
with data protection solutions designed
specifically for clients
who want to extend their data centers to
the cloud
you can try veem on ibm cloud at no cost
for three months
by following the instructions in the
blog linked below
kavonix risk foresight provides
automated compliance and security
posture management from risks due to
cyber threats
and regulatory compliance issues the
built-in vulnerability
configuration checks and compliance
scanners provide continuous assessments
of cloud infrastructure
and the application workloads see the
link below for how to get started with
kavonix on ibm cloud
at no cost for three months thanks for
joining me today for this episode of ibm
cloud now
if you're interested in learning more
about the topics i've covered make sure
you explore the links
in the description of this video and of
course please don't forget to subscribe
to our channel to stay up to date on
what's going on in the cloud
now